you did some interviews like several
years ago you did Rogen you did Chael
Sonnen and you were talking about how
there would be periods of time that your
memory would go away like you'd go like
two three four hours would just kind of
disappear and you you theorized whether
it was a alien abduction or or or what
it was now do you think it was alien
abduction no have you found out what it
was this is the this this is because
people the people they they say that to
me but I looked at this one thing this
this actor for example when you lose
memory you could be like falling asleep
then you wait you know this this could
be slip around paralysis there was more
logical thing there was way more logical
reason for that anything so yeah of
course it the thing is that that what
freaked me out is I saw a movie at some
movie and documentary that people that
claim they got me an abducted by it and
and and then they say they say they are
the same thing that happening to them
that imagine that would be that what I
said is I imagine that if I'm all wrong
about those theory and that's what
happened that would be crazy
you know why see there's way more
logical explanation possibility you
don't know why it is but what we don't
know we don't know but I mean I don't
not think of that and but you did see I
was reading the you and Rashad Evans at
one point did see a UFO is that true I
we were we were we were five people in
the car and when I saw that and if this
is true and I didn't say like that once
again it's people they misunderstand
Claire okay they say alien it doesn't
mean if it's a UH Nintendo five language
app it's an alien it's an identify we
don't know maybe there's a there's
probably an explanation to that we can
explain but at that time we can explain
you know I I read something like most of
an intent an intent of a flying object
when they've been studied there's an
explanation for it there's only a few a
little percentage of it that there is no
small percentage that yes figure out yes
but that was pretty strange and the
thing that what would it look like to me
look does I think that makes it
interesting yes the way I describe it
are different than the way
I described this way that my Mike Van
Arsdale described it the way that ali
abdel aziz described in the way they
another guy
Ali Andrew describe it where were you
guys were in New Mexico
I remember I was we were on the highway
and so kind of a light and the light
went like like it you know like it a
pure kind of I don't know if it's like a
flame but not the color of a flame like
a simile so like a comet that you're a
meteor a meteor but it but it was not
like a meteor was like a he came and you
know like a like a you saw then he then
it you stop seeing then you certain so
it's like a corridor then this hip area
which was strange and I went it happened
we were in the car and I remember when
it happened nobody says nothing after
that after a few second when it happened
is like what that was did anybody think
like I like three you guys before you
guys thinking that was a UFO did one guy
go now was a comp was there one of you
guys that was like no it's just a rock
coming through the atmosphere or all of
you thinking it was something else
well if it was a rock it was a very
strange rock I mean I mean maybe maybe
the angle maybe I don't know I don't
know what it was it okay it's something
that yeah I don't know I never seen
anything like it
what am i it's hard to describe because
there is not really anything compared to
come that I can compare to what are we
thinking if we had to guess earth flat
or round now of course is around okay I
didn't know you guys there's a reason
why you cannot see Mount Everest's from
your from your living room you know even
if you have very strong binocular
because the hard dirt goes you know and
I mean yeah there's you yeah and you
know UFO guy or now you believe in it
UFO I believe there is on and that the
aliens that if you listen to
astrophysicists
guy like me show Kaku and all these guy
my question to him the more the more the
more we know now we know there is a lot
of planet that are like they they're
like hurt like planet you know like the
perfect distance between the
star and they have like you know the
condition that life could could flourish
you know there so it makes it more and
more likely as we learn about the cosmos
that we might not be alone but there we
have no proof of that
I like Michio Kaku but his examples he
does he does kind of use childish
examples see dumb stuff down yes he does
a little bit it does but I think it's to
make people understand yeah he's a very
smart guy very well it's scary but if
he's if he speak with the same language
that astrophysicists speak a guy like me
for example too dumb to understand I'm
not educated anniversary you tried to
make it slip simplify to four people
than the Sandman but he really does like
and I love but he's like you know and
little candy drops you know one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app